Josh Peck was getting 1500 or 3 000 an
episode but also he said he wasn't
getting royalties anymore then Jason is
still getting royalties from Drake and
Josh yeah but Josh wasn't because he was
a kid when he was doing it no because he
was Elite oh wow Nickelodeon they didn't
pay their leads uh residuals but like
guest stars and recurring got residuals
just
some shrewd business from Nickelodeon
yeah you just don't really know what
you're signing as a kid you know it's
not like I didn't have lawyers and
parents like no we knew exactly what we
were signing in between Seasons we were
like okay the show's doing well let's
renegotiate these residuals they're like
we'll recast Ned right now there are
thousands of kids across the country who
would want to do this yeah they're
Savages